every corner of today's earth is
steaming with life from deep caves to
air currents up high from tropical
forests to volcanoes you will find life
at least primitive organisms everywhere
animals plants fungi and bacteria have
learned to adapt to the harshest
environments
has it always been like this in our
world
[Music]
actually our earth has been not the
friendliest of places for the greater
part of its existence
let's cast our mind back to the archaean
eon
the earliest time when life was known to
be around
it began four billion years ago and
continued for approximately one and a
half billion years
the early earth had just gone through
the second heavy bombardment
several thousand tons of rocky debris
from the formation of the solar system
was hurled to the planet smashing the
thin basalt crust that had just formed
on the surface of molten magma even
after this ordeal the young earth cooled
off again and gained its first
lithosphere
just a billion years later it became
home to the very first living organisms
the earth of that period had a
comparatively smooth surface
tectonic plates that is rocky bodies
that create high mountain ridges on
collision were simply non-existent at
that early time
there was no diversity in rocks on the
early earth either
banks of wars and rocks were in the
first stages of formation most of the
earth's crust was made up of the sword a
rock formed from magma and in essence it
is solid lava
there was almost no oxygen in the
atmosphere in the archaean
the concentration of nitrogen was
considerably smaller than it is now
the earth was shrouded in a dense
mixture of water vapor and carbon
dioxide with a high percentage of oxides
of sulfur phosphorus and other active
chemical elements the sun was much
dimmer then than it is now according to
some estimates its luminosity was even
30 percent less than that of today
that is why our planet was quite a murky
place the moon still used to find itself
in close proximity to it so a day lasted
just around 10 hours
as for tidal waves they reached up from
several dozen to 300 meters
as the earth gradually cooled off water
in the atmosphere condensed and poured
down in torrential rains
at first it accumulated in small bodies
of water in lowlands this water was sour
salty and extremely hot up to a boiling
point in some places
its composition resembled that of
today's geezers
paradoxically this seemingly harsh
environment proved to be the cradle for
primitive life forms that originated and
evolved there
it goes without saying that first
organisms were anaerobic
instead of breathing oxygen as we do
which was non-existent in the atmosphere
at the time first living organisms
relied on other sources of energy
archaean organisms were not yet able to
swim in order to survive they needed a
substrate that is why the biosphere of
the time was a thin slimy film of not
more than a millimeter in width on the
bottom of a sour and hot ocean in its
coastal area
the maximal depth the biosphere reached
down was up to 20 meters as the dense
atmosphere did not allow sun rays to
penetrate deeper
the mouths of underwater volcanoes
offered habitats to bacteria that were
chemotrophs these bacteria didn't need
light and fed on other energy sources
relying on chemical reactions between
sulfur compounds and iron
the earth was cooling off sea levels
rose
the atmosphere became more rarefied and
the sun gradually grew in size
the coastal area favorable for life was
also gradually expanding and by the end
of the archaean eon the biosphere was
confined to a thin stripe along the
coasts and also oasis as it were on the
sea bottom near active volcanoes
meanwhile all the land rivers and most
of the open ocean were still completely
devoid of life
if an explorer were to visit the earth
of that period stromatolites would be
the only evidence of life seen with the
naked eye
these sedimentary limestone formations
were created by primordial
microorganisms and may reach up to
several meters in height
there was another problem in that age
the amounts of reagents were
insufficient and that greatly impeded
the evolution of life
evolution hadn't yet produced scavenges
organisms feeding on dead flesh thus
under the influence of gravity and sea
currents dead creatures accumulated in
cavities on the sea floor
hundreds of millions of years later
these accumulations were processed by
nature into what is now oil fields
around three and a half billion years
ago there are emerged creatures that
were to change the earth beyond
recognition
some bacteria got the hang of
photosynthesis involving oxygen
production
a billion years later on the border
between the archaean and the proterozoic
eons their revolution brought about the
most global extinction in the history of
the planet it is known as the oxygen
catastrophe to name but one term
i've spoken in more detail about it in
an earlier video it is hardly possible
to estimate the scale of that event as
an overwhelming majority of the
creatures didn't get preserved as
fossils practically all the diversity of
anaerobic forms that had taken a billion
years to evolve
vanished off the face of the earth
the ancient earth's atmosphere was
exceptionally rich in methane as strong
greenhouse gas
it robustly oxidizes producing carbon
dioxide and water during the process
with methane's concentration in the
atmosphere dropping the temperature on
the planet decreased as well
as a result of this process there
occurred the huronian glaciation
the most large-scale ice age in the
history of the earth which started 2.4
billion years ago and continued for as
long as 300 million years
diggings revealed that in some areas ice
caps reached as far as the equator with
the planet almost totally transformed
into a ball of ice it took the earth one
and a half billion years to go all the
way from boasting boiling lava fields to
endless icy deserts
the proterozoic eon lasted from two and
a half billion years to
440 million years ago
life persevered in spite of the cold and
evolution although thwarted carried on
nevertheless land remained lifeless
living organisms concentrated in the
coastal area near the equator
and what was happening on the continents
even though they weren't crawling with
life yet land was experiencing something
different and interesting in its own way
alongside the continents banks of metal
oars and new rocks were being formed
in the proterozoic eon areas of dry land
alternately assumed different aspects
and were endless glaciers and stone
deserts at one time or another
it is hard to imagine but just a measly
500 million years ago the greater part
of our planet appeared quite like a
martian desert
luckily for all the dwellers of our
planet the sun was growing brighter and
warmer eventually the ice gave in
542 million years ago there began the
phanerozoic eon which is the greek for
the eon of visible life
it was peculiar for periods of active
evolution of different species
interlaced with mass extinctions
i have told you about the major ones
but what was the earth like in those
days
at the beginning of the paleozoic era
the greater part of land formed a giant
supercontinent named gondwana
located in the southern hemisphere it
had elaborate terrain and covered over a
hundred million square kilometers
it was comprised of today's africa south
america antarctica australia
the indian peninsula and some other
areas the smaller continents of the day
lorentia baltica and siberia were
situated near the equator
apart from all that there was a great
number of smaller islands
still up until the silurian period which
started approximately
444 million years ago there weren't any
life forms to speak of on all these
expanses
only some simple mosses and lichens were
slowly establishing their dominance on
land it was only at the beginning of the
silurian period that first plants
emerged in tidal areas and near rivers
and only in the tropical zone at that
even in spite of the fact that sea
species and plants became more diverse
marine life forms still concentrated
near the coasts
the area populated incrementally
expanded
just to give you an example the depth of
the ocean at which photosynthesis was
able to take place in the devonian was
just 50 meters
which is 10 times as little as it is now
in the same period which began
420 million years ago and continued
until
358 million years ago the first
decomposers emerged organisms
decomposing dead flesh as a result their
emerged organisms feeding on products of
decomposition
for example alongside scavenging
bacteria there could be found sea
sponges at depths of up to 500 meters
the next period was the carboniferous
period it continued from 358 to
299 million years ago by the time it
began the greater part of the tropical
zone was covered with tree ferns
dense tropical forests did not grow as a
mass
there were no organisms back then that
would help would decompose that is why
bulky trunks of trees didn't trot when
they died and didn't pass any nutrients
to their descendants
they remained lying without decaying and
the phosphorus in their bodies so vital
for plants couldn't be extracted thus
with time lush sapi virgia gave way to
enormous heaps of dead wood covering
enormous stretches of land
later they formed rich deposits of coal
which is still widely used by mankind in
various industries
in areas other than the tropics only
fungi mosses and lichens could be found
they were not able to harden the upper
layer of the earth by their roots
and as a result rain easily washed it
off with rivers turning into muddy
streams and lakes becoming putrid swamps
dry areas became lifeless deserts
it was a time when fishes were
vigorously evolving in the seas and
rivers although life hadn't yet ventured
out into the open ocean
algae hadn't learned to float yet
and so life was still confined to
coastal areas
the carboniferous period was followed by
the permian period
it began
299 and finished
252 million years ago
the first amphibians dared to start
exploring land and plants spread to
conquer subtropics
the sea remained populated only in
shallow waters close to the coasts
the permian period finished with the
most massive extinction event in the
history of multicellular life according
to some estimates up to 96 of marine
species and 73 percent of land species
died out
it is still not known what caused such a
global mortality
the triassic period of the mesozoic era
promptly made up for the lost time
bringing life to a new level during the
process
for the first time in history of the
earth temperate latitudes could boast
some woods
another revolutionary event took place
in the sea where blue green algae
emerged a type resembling their today's
descendants
it was not vital for them to live in a
substrate anymore and so photosynthetic
microorganisms quickly spread across the
upper layer of the global ocean
tempted by the food fishes mollusks and
arthropods followed it
organic leftovers settled on the sea
bottom thus sea bottom dwellers were
amply supplied with food as well
the global ocean was assuming an aspect
close to today's
the mesozoic era lasted from 250 to 66
million years ago it is subdivided into
three periods the triassic the jurassic
and the cretaceous
this is when dinosaurs thrived
admittedly the most well-known
prehistoric creatures that became
subject of feature and science fiction
movies
the way these ages are depicted we might
get the idea that the earth was covered
with tropical forests from the poles to
the equator
in fact it is completely wrong
indeed forests reached northern
latitudes but only because the average
temperature on the planet was much
higher than it is now
meanwhile equatorial areas on the
contrary suffered droughts
with the forests rapidly spreading
across the entire earth's surface there
were still lots of swamps and deserts
around
the latters were not only scorching hot
and dry as we're used to picturing them
but also moderate cool and even humid
with no herbaceous plants around soils
could not attach themselves to rocky
slopes
only lichens are able to grow on barren
rocks
flowering plants became abundant only by
the middle of the cretaceous period
that is around a hundred million years
ago
interestingly the first varieties were
trees and by the end of the period there
emerged plants similar to today's herbs
compared to a mighty oak or a giant
sequoia
regular grass appears insignificant
but it is capable of something tree
giants aren't
by mingling their tiny roots on the
ground they help form and strengthen the
turf this not only makes soil tougher
and prevents it from getting washed off
or eroding but also takes care of
getting rid of excess water by letting
it evaporate and accumulating water when
there is a lack of it
on emerging herbaceous plants turned
deserts into steps prairies and savannas
swamps into flood meadows and permafrost
areas into tundra and tundra step
by the time the cretaceous period was
coming to its end the earth had started
to resemble the earth of today
it was lacking just one important touch
mammals
this type of animals had been around for
a long while
but the creatures were not very
widespread until the end of the mesozoic
era
it is still not clear what caused
dinosaurs to become extinct
a giant meteorite global cooling and
other suggestions are listed among the
supposed culprits
either way these giant saurians vanished
thus vacating a special niche for
mammals it took them 66 million years to
evolve from tiny marsupials into
majestic whales dangerous tigers tough
camels and amusing bats
eventually evolution produced a unique
species
the only living creature capable of not
only adapting to nature but also
changing it the being that extracts coal
formed of all those dead trees from
millions of years ago to warm up one's
dwelling
the creature exterminating other species
for money of a
sport the creature turning vast areas
into wasteland in pursuit of selfish
motives
this is homo sapiens or the human
dear friends it has taken us quite a
while and a lot of effort to make this
video that is why we really appreciate
every single like you give us
your support is a great motivation for
us to carry on making new videos for all
of you to enjoy
feel free to tell us what you think in
the comments below
let's keep in touch
so
[Music]
you